new in theaters this weekend Dumbo what  will you see this is your weekend ticket  [Music]  Dumbo flies onto the big screen this  weekend this live-action remake was  inspired by the original 1941 animated  Disney movie which was originally based  on the novel Dumbo and outcast elephant  with oversized ears is born to a  struggling circus yes something very  rare you have wonder  they soon discovered that his most  embarrassing feature is what allows him  to fly both into the sky and into our  hearts  [Music]  ah this film is directed by Tim Burton  so it's the classic Dumbo story with a  burton-esque dark gothic twist this  movies for you if you loved the original  you're digging the new make classic  Disney movies live-action movement or  you've ever felt self-conscious about  your big ears forget about it  your beautiful that is your weekend  ticket what will you see and check back  next week for Zachary Levi as Shazam  [Music]  you